carl
carl where'd you grow up where you from
originally i'm from
evansville kentucky
tell me about your uh tell me about your
childhood
with your parents as a kid yes um
i'm the youngest boy out of nine boys
and uh i have six
sisters and my mother
i was kind of like around my mother a
lot because i was the baby boy and i was
always at home
and um i enjoyed um
tinkering around with musical
instruments
um and stuff like that so
my mother had a lot of boyfriends
um that was around us because my father
wasn't around
um my father lived in another state
actually
and my father i never did to get the
chance to meet my father until i was
13 years old um
my mother had a my mother had a
boyfriend
his name was jonathan
um he was kind of office type of guy
worked in an office there and
um i used to be
sort of what fond of him because he
would always take me in the room
and watch cartoons with me when i was a
kid
and um he would call my sisters
all the time to the door and tell him
they couldn't come in then he would put
me out
on the door and that's when i learned
about molestation he started molesting
my sisters
all three of my sisters when my mother
was at work
and after that
happened so long and so much he knew
that i
would tell my mother but i was scared to
tell my mother
that he was doing that so i was the next
next object he would always take me in
the room and
moles just fondled me
and
i would always be scared of him and i
would try to climb out the window and
run away
and they would always find me and he'll
wait a week or two and then
try to fund me and he'd follow me again
um it just my childhood was
a little bit complex because it seems
like
i went to count my camp director he was
trying to do the same thing with
some of the guys in there and i caught
him
touching me uh early in the morning
said he was checking on me to see what i
sleep was
i was sleeping and i found his hands
inside my underwear um
i didn't like going to camp anymore
because i thought that
if you go to camp you you know that
that was the thing about cam you have to
get molested and i didn't want to go to
camp anymore
i tried my mother tried
having me to stay with her
best friend's son which he was an older
person which i admired because he ran
track
and i always wanted to run track and
um he would always have me
on his back and pl in the room let me
sleep in the bed with him
and the next day that i know i woke up
and he was on top of me
and i felt something wet in between my
you know my legs and i thought i had
pooped on myself
and i got scared of him and i never
would go back
over there my mother was asking me why i
don't go back over there
to eat lunch or dinner go out hang out
or go to a movie and i never told her
i just started thinking that anytime
that i did something
i was going to be molested no matter
what it was
then my mother made me go to texas to
meet my father
at 13 and i didn't really want to go
on the greyhound bus by myself i was
scared i was about to get out
in another state because i thought the
same thing was going to happen to me
with my father
i just didn't know how to deal with this
it took me a lot of years to learn
to get this out i never would tell
anybody because
i didn't want anybody to think that oh i
enjoyed it or i liked it or
something like that i just felt ashamed
that people would know that this
happened to me but i feel now that i'm
not alone because i'm not the only one
that this
had happened to and i remember
my mother's boyfriend used to make me
stand in the closet
naked until i decided to let him
fondle me and sometimes i was sitting
there for six
seven hours i wouldn't come out the
closet
because i knew my mother would be home
and sometimes she would work overtime
and i would be in a man
until about 11 and 12 o'clock at night
and um
it was hard for me to
deal with a whole lot of stuff because i
didn't want to come home because i
thought
that was the only life that was going to
be for me was getting molested
by someone or i couldn't talk to anybody
uh i felt out of place if i went to my
friend's house and their father was at
home with us when we were watching tv
i was always thinking that hurricane's
father was gonna molest me and i always
sit
close to the corner and the door
just to run out of there and
i was really frightened and scared about
a whole
lot of things you know about dealing
with males
because i thought everybody was going to
try to molest me
and i never would tell anybody because i
thought they would laugh at me
and
until this day um
it's hard to deal with sometimes but
i try to do i tried to do a lot of other
things to get me through it
um i got myself through college i went
to
texas southern university and
i didn't finish college when i i i tried
to go to a lot of other schools
just to get away from it and
it's taken me a long time to talk about
to talk about it because it's something
that i've always
hid because uh i just feel
that it's so unspeakable for a person to
do
a young child like that and
i just i just didn't know what to do so
now
i talk i try get counseling to talk
about and it's
it's taken somewhat uh
weight lifted a lot of weight off of me
somewhat
but i i'm still kind of like curious and
shaky even though i'm a lot older now
and
i'm real focused on what people do and
what people say
around children i'm very protective i
have a daughter
very overprotective about my daughter
because
i just don't want the same thing to
happen to me
that happened to me happened to her and
i don't want
any other kid to have to go through that
so
[Music]
i try to be a person that can
slowly talk about this with them and
try to turn a negative into a positive
and if this can help anyone
you know um just find someone that you
can trust
and that you can talk to and is willing
to hear your story um
it gets a lot better in the end
takes a lot of weight off for you
and um those are the things that i've
been through uh it's scary
when you go through this through life
and you think you might get molested in
the gym
you think everything that you do you're
going to get molested and that's how i
lived my life for quite a few years
even as an adult i had jobs i would
think that the boss would try to get me
and molest me you know i was always
thinking
something was funny anytime i went out
with somebody
uh they were trying to molest me so i
kind of like isolated myself
and ran away a lot uh from a whole lot
of stuff
i walked away from one job when the guy
put his
hands around me just you know to
pat me you know like hey man and i never
came back to work the next day
um
i just never um came back to work
and i'm just kind of like um
a little bit unbalanced still but
i get through it you know i get through
it now
and uh it's just
something i just want to share with with
you
with people that you don't have to be
afraid
um there are some good
people uh
you go and meet them you know you go to
hell
going to have to tell them what's going
on with you
please don't be afraid to tell no one
that you're
being molested or anything
try to stop it before it continues
[Music]
and i'm glad um it stopped
for me um but i still have dreams and
stuff
uh middle stuff i think about it
you know and i wish i would have died or
something like that
but uh i'm here for a reason and
uh maybe this is the reason for me
to express that you know
there you can there is help there is
people that can help you get through
this
and i'm getting through it right now
it's a little difficult at times but i
have my days where i just
isolate myself from people family
members
because i think about some of the stuff
that happened to me but um
i just just keep going
how has this affected you as an adult
like your adult relationships
um with women or with men with
with with women because i don't
i don't like meeting their kids because
i don't want them to think that
the same thing happened to me is going
to happen to the kids
um is there a temptation on your part
that
something might happen no there's no
temptations just
the stigma of me being honest and seeing
this is what happened to me as a
child and uh
they might want you to meet their sons
or their daughters and
and um
they got the stigma that you're molester
or something like that because if you've
been
molested you're gonna do it to someone
else and
it's not true never happened
never happened i'm just overprotective
of the kids
i know they're not my kids but i'm very
overprotective because i don't want
things to happen to them what happened
to me to happen to them i just don't
i just don't want that to happen to any
child um
if i can help anyone i i will you know i
can and i will i think i'm to a point in
my life to where i
i can settle and i can deal with certain
things
this to a certain degree i get angry a
lot at myself
sometime you know i don't work anymore
because i can sit at a desk or something
like that and i get to thinking about
this and it
bothers me um and it affects my job
um work that i do sometimes
so the emotional damage it causes yeah
continues on still today
yeah yeah it does uh as i was talking to
you
it brought up a little it brought up
some feelings um
i just like raised the dead it just
brought up some feelings that i was
unavailable but
i know there's a power greater than
myself that helps me um
get through this and uh that's what
pulled me back
and lets me know that everything's gonna
be all right for me
even today as being an adult it's gonna
be all right
and i think the more that i talk about
this you know my
mother used to say before she died when
you're going through something the
hardest part is
over and i guess me speaking on this the
hardest part is over
and uh
i guess i'm i i get through this i get
through this
pretty good
yeah and my mother uh
rest in peace and my father uh both of
them deceased
and most of the people and even my
mother's um
boyfriend mr jonathan is rest in peace
and
they're all most of everybody that that
tried it with me are all gone now
and uh it's just a heck of a thing to
deal with
you know when they're not around for you
to tell them how you feel
um it's disturbing
to me because there's a whole lot of
stuff i wanted to say to them before
that happened but what would you say to
the people that molested you if you
could
why did you molest me
what gave you the right
to touch my person
you know what gave you the right to harm
me
you know what gave me that right what
did i do with the child
to make that happen
[Music]
do i forgive them
it was hard as hell man but yeah i do
i forgive them nobody's perfect
people make mistakes
but i try to stay focused and uh
make sure it doesn't happen again so
that's basically
that's what happened to me and
what's the most important lesson you've
learned from all of this
go talk tell someone
go tell someone because if you don't
it's gonna it's gonna follow you and
haunt you for
all your days like it does me for a lot
of years i
i've never said anything to people about
this
you know it doesn't make you
a gay person or anything like that you
know
if you say something like that people
think that you're gay now
because it happened to you no i was a
helpless little boy
and uh i didn't have anybody
yeah all right well thank you so much
for sharing your story
thank you for having me
best of luck thank you great job thank
you